entire neighborhoods flooded across
Eastern Libya the worst storm the
country has seen in years Mediterranean
stormed Daniel brought record rainfall
in the city of El baida people can only
watch as their vehicles are washed away
patients and staff were forced to
evacuate several hospitals local
officials are calling for immediate
assistance
we announce with regret that the
situation is completely out of control
we call on all government officials to
intervene to save what can be saved
governments are responsible for people's
lives request the security services to
provide assistance
Libya has been engulfed by political
divisions for more than a decade the
country has two governments that slowed
down emergency assistance efforts
the parallel government in eastern Libya
has announced a two-day state of
emergency
enforcing a curfew and calling for
people to exercise caution if they leave
their homes the internationally
recognized government in Tripoli
declared Eastern Libya a disaster Zone
it sent teams of emergency workers from
Western Libya
I've instructed the Ministry of Health
and all relevant agencies to quickly
provide assistance relief convoys will
be dispatched to all cities affected by
this incident we will respond with all
available resources
the impact of storm Daniel on Eastern
Libya has been devastating local
officials say many people remain missing
with search and rescue operations
currently underway there are fears the
death toll will only rise and
forecasters have issued a red warning
saying more storms are on their way now
trainer Al Jazeera
and Malik joins us now from Tripoli
Malek let's just talk about the
situation it's serious with so many
deaths but it's all about getting that
Aid and relief effort to the region how
difficult is that practically
considering there is so much civil
Strife across East and Western Libya
well it's extremely difficult uh so hey
what we've seen from Western Libya prime
minister Abdel Hameed has ordered uh the
uh the authorities the relevant agencies
to immediately uh head towards Eastern
Libya they did that this morning around
five five in the morning local time we
saw large convoys with excavators
bulldozers ambulances uh hundreds of of
volunteers uh making their way towards
Eastern Libya they should be arriving
very shortly but the situation is
extremely serious and some are starting
to call it a catastrophe like like
earlier when you when you talked about
the dams collapsing in the city of
delnas the the city of delna is
completely surrounded by mountains and
these dams collapsed some experts are
saying more than 30 million cubic square
meters of water has has uh was was was
dumped into the City and we're starting
to see pictures of entire neighborhoods
uh destroyed so there's fears that this
the death toll can rise tremendously the
next couple of hours
and of course uh Malik one of the the
real worries would be that while it's
being reported that 150 people uh have
been killed that death toll could rise
because of the area that's been affected
and it is a wide area isn't it
oh it's extremely it's extremely wide
and and various towns and Villages uh
and cities across Eastern Libya and
let's not forget Libya has two
governments so uh you know with these
large convoys coming from Western Libya
arriving in the East that could really
complicate uh us assistance the the
efforts to help people in need I mean
who's going to supervise uh those those
efforts and and the volunteers and the
people that are there so so uh you know
the hope is that uh in this tragedy
perhaps uh the the Rival authorities can
come together and try to help the people
in need I mean they're in desperate need
of assistance so we're going to have to
wait and see how this situation develops
thanks very much for the latest